So today I want to talk about
Social anxiety.
And is it just me,
or when you know you're gonna meet
someone for the first time,
are you like, freaking out about how
you're gonna greet them?
Do I just wave, or is that considered rude?
Maybe I should shake her hand, no
that's too formal..
Should I hug her? That's weird.
She's weirded out by you. You lost.
And even before that interaction
happens, if I know that I'm going
to meet someone, I create mock
conversations in my head
to be prepared.
It's sorta like doing imaginary improv with
yourself to prepare for the "big show"
even though the "big show" is really just
meeting someone face to face
rather than face to screen.
And I'm so weird around strangers.
I become overcompensatingly polite,
like, DISGUSTINGLY polite.
But this comes with a negative aspect
because if I'm polite to someone
and they don't reciprocate,
then I get really upset.
Hey!
Asshole!
I held open this fucking door for you
and you don't even want to say "thanks"?
Who do you think YOU are?
Next time, you could just
hold open this fucking door
by yourself, okay?!
Have a nice life!
Bitch.
I'm exaggerating, it really goes like..
Oh, let me get that.
Bitch.
Lately, social interation..
or, even just the idea of
social interaction
has given me the same anxiety
that I used to feel right before
I went on stage.
And that is ridiculous, alright?
Those are not the same thing.
And look, I mean this video
is very lighthearted, obviously
it's for comedy.
There's a lot of generalizations
and ridiculous jokes in it.
Um, but anxiety is something that
I need to laugh at, and I need
to make jokes about, in order to
convince myself that I have a really
solid grip on it.
If you are suffering from anxiety,
uh, what I found works best for me,
is try to change my perspective on it.
So you have to convince yourself
that it is not frightening, no,
it is an exciting adventure~
And yeah, it may sound gay,
but..I really don't care at this point
because..
I don't know about you,
but..
I don't to be a pussy for the rest of my life.
Just saying.